hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control mp.l 2-3.8.5 control access
to Media containing cui and maintain
accountability for media during
transport outside of controlled areas
let's find out what that's about
[Music]
say if you're a defense contractor who's
feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all the cmmc dfars
and nist SP 10171 compliant stuff on top
of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news for you if you found
your home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's Don the cape and
get into it all right first step is
control you know that authorized users
must always be in control of cui media
at all times that's an easy one but now
for the accountability site how do we do
that well there are lots of ways and
actually the rules are pretty flexible
But ultimately we solved this with
something called a cui media access log
essentially a log of any media which may
contain cui outside the primary main
company Network examples are of course
USB thumb drives portable hard drives
DVDs and paper media and we draw the
line at the physical secure facility or
Enclave environment if it's leaving that
it should be accounted for we like the
cui media log idea and of course it's
should be controlled by the custodian of
that media for a more formal answer
let's dive into a sample answer and what
the assessors are looking for on this
one
so uh first assessment Point determine
if access to Media containing Cy is
controlled implemented only authorized
cui handling users have access to system
systems containing cui media is only
accessible via express authorization
from the IT team and where applicable
documented within the cui media access
log so again the idea is you know in the
control is can you even get to it right
that's the control part second piece
determine if accountability
accountability for media contains UI is
maintained during transport outside of
controlled areas that's where the cui
media access log comes in and that's
going to be what your answer is there so
again first one is is a controlled prior
to you staff from other other controls
no pun intended there and then the
second one is the accountability and
that's where the media log really comes
into place so hey in on call we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this DeForest nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped in their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray area areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmccompliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content that we're putting out
here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash the Subscribe button to get
the latest compliance content as soon as
our compliance starts roll it out until
next supplies tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there let us know in the
comments below what you'd like to learn
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next one
[Music]
thank you